welcome back to whatsit Wednesday this
is episode number 13
last week's guest right here was indeed
an osprey like many of you guessed the
first person to get that right was Odie
and actually you were the first person
to comment so that's that was pretty
cool that's never happened before we
never had the first commenter also be
the first person to get it right so good
work good work my friend
the dead giveaway for most people was
where the talons here especially the
rough texture doesn't focus especially
the rough texture on the feet on the
bottoms of the feet
Osprey hunt fish and because of that
they have extremely textured feet if you
compare that to a red-tailed hawk it's
pretty much just smooth and the other
cool thing about the Osprey is that this
toe right here is movable it can go to
the back actually sorry yeah it's this
toe that moves you can move it backwards
not in this dried specimen but that
allows them to really really get a
really solid grip on a fish no matter
how its wiggling no matter what happens
to be going on so these are excellent
excellent hunters Osprey it's one of my
favorite birds of prey they're super
pretty unfortunately they don't do well
in captivity and the reason for that is
that hunting is part of their ritual for
eating grabbing those fish out of the
water and they really don't want to eat
pre-killed
food or even food that's still alive but
they don't dive down to hunt it I assume
that they've developed kind of a phobia
of food that they did not kill
themselves because I don't know maybe
fish go bad so so quickly that they
evolve to this habit to only eat what
they kill themselves but sadly that
means that they don't do well in
captivity it's really rare when we're
rehabilitating injured Osprey we have to
force-feed them and it's it's super
stressful for them but we only do it for
a couple of weeks while they're
recovering then we then we set them free
again so yeah Osprey amazing animals
this week's guest is absolutely
fascinating because of these sclerotic
bones and the eye most of the birds that
I've showed you so far we're missing
these bones they're you know they're
fairly delicate
all birds have them so far as I know and
actually almost all vertebrates have
them the only group of Reiter Brits that
don't have them consistently are mammals
and I think crocodiles have lost them as
well but don't quote me on that but the
sclerotic
ring allows the eyes of these different
animals to be weird shaped they don't
have to be round notice that in this
bird the eyes are they're really big in
the back like inside the skull cavity
here that the eyes are huge in the back
so their retina can be huge on these
animals but these bones act kind of like
a kind of like a belt they're actually
embedded in the flesh of the eye the
white part of the eye and then the eye
bulges out the end here just like that
and in the case of this animal it can't
really move its eyes its eyes are too
big but in some other birds they can
move their eyes still it's like these
bones are fused with the skull they are
independent of the skull I mean in this
case they're glued in afterwards
but so yeah those are these sclerotic
rings there's a really cool website and
I've got a link to it in the video
description where you can learn about
those rings and learn about the anatomy
of bird eyes they're really amazing you
know in our eyes we have these blood
vessels that run across the retina and
they you know supply blood to the retina
well in birds they have a structure
called the pectin instead they don't
have blood vessels they have this little
chunk of flesh that sticks out into the
eye and it's covered in blood vessels
and it uses the the juice inside the eye
as a medium to transport things from the
blood to these cells inside the eye
inside the retina so it's it's really
that's that's why birds have such better
eyesight when compared to mammals it's
one of the reasons that they have such
better eyesight than us now a lot of you
are like I'm probably thinking right now
hey show us the talons to that animal I
want to see what its feet look like
because that was such a help with the
Osprey well it just so happens that okay
fine I will show you the talons here
they are
look at this creature I really like this
specimen because it looks like it has
fur but that is not for those are
feathers and I don't know that I'll be
able to even get here I have tried my
best to isolate a single feather for you
to prove that this is feathers and not
fur you can see it it's this fan-like
structure
but those feathers gone all the way down
the feet help it stay warm
when it's hunting
so these are its talons this is its
skull what do you think it is
what's it Wednesday
pretty dang cool look at underneath here
such a bizarre animal no googling as
usual can't wait to see your comments in
the comment section yeah I don't know
his tongues like sandpaper that's funny
you're cute you're cute I don't have
anymore I'm all out of grass I don't
know
thank give you scratches so funny that
cows gonna have upper teeth upper
incisors how'd you lose your teeth huh
I'm sort of evolutionary Salinas is that